In this video, we'll explore various optimization techniques to ensure that our Datasmith project
can run at an acceptable frame rate for our application.
When considering the work that goes into achieving performance, we often have to consider how
that balances against quality and features.
It is often thought of as a triangle where you can sit somewhere within here, but you
cannot achieve all three of these equally.
With enough knowledge of engine optimization tools, you may find that you're able to buy
back performance.
Draw calls is one aspect of optimization that you'll hear often discussed.
Draw calls represent a package of triangles sent to the GPU, and the GPU renders draw
call by draw call, not triangle by triangle.
Note that each mesh and material represents a different draw call, which means that if
you have three objects, even if they have the same material, they will still represent
three draw calls, and one object with two materials will represent two draw calls.
You can profile draw calls at any time using statRHI, this is the same command we used
earlier when looking at Nanite and Triangles drawn, and that's a particularly useful statistics
window to keep an eye on as you can see both triangle count and draw calls side by side.
Once again, every project is different, but as a rule of thumb, desktop and console experiences
often want between 2,000 and 4,000 draw calls as a maximum, virtual reality 800 to 1200,
and mobile devices 200 to 400.
One of the ways Unreal Engine tries to auto-optimize the scene, and you can play to the strengths
of this, is Unreal Engine will attempt to not render what it can't see in the scene,
and this can mean both the camera frustrum, what the camera can actually see in the current
screen space, as well as objects that are hidden by other objects.
So in this case, we can't see the motorcycle behind the wall, so that could get cold, but
then we also can't see the motorcycle behind the camera, and so that also gets cold.
If you have very high triangle count objects, especially with a lot of draw calls, consider
separating them from each other so they are rarely seen at the same time.
Changing actors is a way to reduce draw calls.
You can select a number of static meshes in your scene, and then generate a single static
mesh from them.
You can preserve the geometry, which would mean you have no reduction in triangle count,
but if there are shared materials, that will reduce draw calls without changing anything
else about the objects.
Note this can be an issue for very large objects, we're looking at a corner of the
object will still require rendering the entire thing, as those other previous elements which
were separate are no longer called out, and it can be an issue for animated actors where
you're dealing with skeletal meshes and bones and animation data.
Another option you have when you're combining actors is to generate proxies.
In this case, instead of the geometry being preserved, it's simplified and can result
in a lower quality mesh based on parameters that you choose.
As part of that, you can even combine the materials into one single texture and material
family.
One option you have during this process is to combine all the materials.
This is something worth playing with.
There are many options when generating proxies, so be sure to experiment with them in order
to ensure that you achieve the results that you're after.
For our final exercise, we'll review a number of objects in a scene and figure out the best
way to combine them.
Thank you.
Bye.